H
OVERWHELMING NUMBERS.
SEAN?
>> Sean: GRIFF JENKINS MEXICO
SNICKER THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
IS FORMER TEXAS GOVERNOR, RICK
PERIOD.
I WAS DONE AT THE BORDER A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO WITH YOU AS
THAT AS IT WAS THEN IT IS WAS
NOT WE HAVE HAD GOVERNOR ABBOTT
ON THE PROGRAM A LOT OF TIME.
>> CALLED UP THE NATIONAL GUARD.
HE HAS ALLOCATED $3 BILLION IN
TEXAS FUNDS, TEXAS TAXPAYERS
PAYING, HE HAS ACTUALLY TREATED
MILES OF HIS OWN WALL USING
TROLL CARS FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND AT EVERY STEP OF THE WAKE OF
HIS BATTLE IS REALLY WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AIDING AND
BIT -- BETTING THAT LAW.
WHAT OTHER OPTIONS -- THE
GOVERNOR HAVE AT THIS POINT?
>>> LET ME --
>> LET ME JUST THINK ONE THING
THING.
THANK YOU FOR TELLING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE TRUTH.
AS I FLIP THROUGH CHANNELS, IT
IS REALLY DIFFICULT TO FIND THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON IN
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THIS IS A DEVASTATING WAVE THAT
IS HITTING OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS LYING
ABOUT IT.
I THINK IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT YOU AND YOUR NETWORK,
OTHERS, TELL THE TRUTH.
AND HOLD JOE BIDEN ACCOUNTABLE.
HOLD MAYORKAS ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE FACE OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND LYING TO
THEM ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON ON
THAT SOUTHERN BORDER.
THERE ARE FAMILIES THAT ARE
BEING DEVASTATED BECAUSE OF
THIS.
AND MAYBE WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
JUST HIRE EVERY TRUST THAT WE
CAN HIRE IN THE STATE OF TEXAS
HIGHER EVERY -- HIRE EVERY
CHARTER AIRCRAFT, BRING THE
NATIONAL GUARD C-130S TO THE
BORDER AND LOAD THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
AND TAKE THEM TO MARYLAND AND
LEAVE THEM THERE.
AND MAYBE --
[OVERLAPPING SPEAKERS]
>> Sean: YOU ARE HITTING ON
SOMETHING IMPORTANT HERE,
GOVERNOR OR SECRETARY, I DON'T
KNOW WHICH YOU PREFER.
WHICHEVER TITLE YOU LIKE, YOU
WON'T THEM ALL.
BUT THE IMPORTANT THING IS, ONE
THING HERE AND JOE LEFT THEM IN.
WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DEPORT THEM.
BECAUSE THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE ROLE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ENFORCE THE LAW
AND THEY DISPERSED PEOPLE, NO
TEST.
NO VACCINE MANDATE ALL AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND THEN PEOPLE COME
WITHOUT ANY MONEY AND STATES
BEAR THE BURDEN OF FOOD AND
SHELTER AND EDUCATION AND
HEALTHCARE AND WE CAN'T BALANCE
OUR BUDGET.
IT IS NOT COMPLICATED MATH HERE.
>> BUT ALL OF THIS BIG
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL IS NOT GOING
TO COST ANYTHING.
I HAVE HEARD THAT PRESIDENT LOOK
INTO THE CAMERA AND SAY, THIS IS
GOING TO COST ZERO.
AND SEAN THAT IS BLIND TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I MEAN, HE IS PLAYING AMERICANS
FOR CHUMPS.
AND PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR HIM,
THEY NEED TO REALLY TAKE A DEEP
BREATH, THINK ABOUT WHAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL IS DOING TO THIS
COUNTRY.
IT IS STAGGERING WHAT IS
HAPPENING ALONG THAT BORDER.
YOU KNOW, THOSE WHO HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN DEMOCRAT
VOTERS IN THOSE COUNTIES ALONG
THE RIO GRANDE, I WILL TELL YOU
ONE THING, THEY ARE RETHINKING
THAT TODAY.
AND THEY ARE LOOKING AT JOE
BIDEN AND GOING, THIS IS
POTENTIALLY THE BIGGEST MISTAKE
WE EVER MADE IN OUR LIVES LET
THIS INDIVIDUAL BECOME THE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: I WILL ADD TO THAT